on
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
deux événements marquants cette semaine
c'est le festival de mainz qui s'est
terminée avec la victoire de wisches
manhattan à nantes contre vladimir
kramnik le match des champions du monde
également la victoire de stuart frank
west à clichy victoire éclatante avec
une superbe partie à la dernière seconde
contre jean-marc degraeve aujourd'hui
pour commenter cette actualité ne j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir le grand maître
international
jean-luc chavanon bonjour jean luc
bonjour eloi grand maître international
donc c'est tout nouveau
tu viens d'obtenir le titre c'était
comment je viens d'obtenir le titre et
j'attends juste parce que c'est plus il
faut quand même préciser aux
téléspectateurs que l'obtention du titre
de grand matin en salle se fait en
plusieurs étapes
il faut faire les normes de granby
international obtenir le classement de
plus de 2500 points elo et dans un
troisième temps à voir donc
l'approbation de la fédération
internationale des échecs donc c'est pas
encore fait mais c'est pour bientôt
c'est pour bientôt tu as donc tous les
éléments requis pour devenir un grand
maître c'est donc prévu pour le prochain
congrès de la fidh et ton actualité en
ce moment c'est évidemment la
préparation du national le championnat
de france individuel où tu auras à faire
quand même
les meilleurs joueurs français et oui
donc ça va être ça fait un tournoi très
très très très élevé le plus fort
championnat de france qui n'ait jamais
lieu depuis depuis sa création
et donc je vais me préparer je vais
d'abord commencer par le championnat de
paris et après je vais me préparer donc
pour ce grand rendez-vous championnat
paris fin juillet donc tu participera au
tournoi on couvrira évidemment cet
événement championnat de france du 15 au
30 août donc là ça va être très chaud ça
sera couvert bien entendu mais tout de
suite l'actualité c'est le tournoi de
clichy pour commencer avec victoire
incroyable de stuart frank west dans ce
catégorie 14
jean-luc événement intéressant c'est le
tournoi le plus fort que start comme
quoi ce n'est jamais joué et il le gagne
est ce qu'une signification
psychologique ça institut art est un
joueur qui
qui aime les défis qui a toujours fait
des résultats en dents de scie et
actuellement il est plutôt dans la phase
ascendante
donc ces résultats sont de mieux en
mieux il s'est qualifié pour le
championnat du monde il y à il ya trois
semaines et il se dit vigilant jours de
très très fort open qui avait lieu à
ohrid voilà le champion d'europe en
étant donné la garantie 1er voilà il a
terminé plus très très bien placé et il
se devait puisque c'est un joueur qui
joue pour le club de clichy c'était les
20 ans du club de clichy qui était
organisée donc à clichy et pour ses 20
ans il se devait en tant que vieux
piliers de l'équipe de championnat de
france par équipes ils devaient se
devait donc de faire un très très bon
résultat c'est ce qu'il a fait histoire
comme quoi c'est donc un grand maître
anglais qui n'a jamais eu des résultats
vraiments éclatant qui doit voir quel
âge 32 33 ans
oui je pense que vu oui je pense je
dirais qu'il a 33 ou 35 ans 33 35 ans
donc c'est un joueur qui a priori ne
devrait plus progresser en toute logique
et pourtant il est capable de faire des
pique à ses fulgurants comme évidemment
ici en remportant le tournoi fermé la
catégorie 14 donc plus de 2550 de
moyenne et l'eau devant miragoâne beach
devant joël lautier qui sont quand même
de grand maître expérimenté et très très
fort oui je pense qu'il a il envoyait sa
technique favorite c'est la technique
très très british très relax il a décidé
donc de prendre les parties comme elles
viennent
il l'a
et il avait donc souligné lors d'une
interview pour le pur
pour canal web je crois et donc voilà il
a pris il a pris les parties comme elles
sont venues store conquoise premiers
deuxièmes ex-aequo nous avons joël
lautier normal oui en résulte un mot
disons un peu décevant on peu décevant
puisque joël lautier qui vient d'obtenir
donc un très très fort classement donc
qui est qui reprend la tête de numéro un
français donc on s'attendait à ce que
joël lautier confirme donc cette tête
mais bon il talonne de très très près le
vainqueur du tournoi c'est quand même
pas si mal
marc ebden lui c'est également un grand
maître anglais qui est donc plus vieux
buteur franck west qui est vraiment de
l'ancienne génération anglaise mais qui
ici réd une très très belle performance
donc avec cinq points et demi sur neuf
c'est pas mal du tout 2e ex-aequo donc
on peut dire un duo anglais bien relevé
et oui donc les anglais qui se prépare
activement pour leur championnat
national puisqu'il faut dire aussi que
les joueurs anglais auront un
championnat très relevé aussi donc au
mois deux mois d'août est donc marqué
ben et stuart conquest sont très motivés
l'actualité faisant donc il
il m ils font quelques réglages et ils
sont très très très très dangereux
actuellement dans ce qu'on réfléchisse
nous retrouvons ensuite des grands
maîtres comme pavel très gougov
christian bauer igor nataf qui fait pas
une très bonne perf olivier rhône et qui
n'a pas très bien joué dû à son manque
de compétition mais tout de suite nous
allons passer à la partie commenter
cette partie ça sera une partie de
stuart conquest
évidemment grand vainqueur de ce tournoi
à la dernière ronde ils étaient égalité
avec joël haute il devait remporter
cette partie pour gagner ils jouent
contre jean-marc degraeve une partie
explosive jean-luc mais une partie
explosive jean-marc comme d'habitude qui
prend des risques
blanc ou noir donc là il a pris des
risques avec les noirs et
la position est devenue tendue très
rapidement comme on va le voir tout de
suite nous allons mettre l'échiquier
pour vous commenter la partie de la
semaine
l'échiquier le voilà la partie de la
c'est donc la partie ce tueur ton quest
jean-marc degraeve ouverture assez
irrégulière on va voir ça tout de suite
ils jouent des 4 jusqu'au la normale
tout éclat si cavani et six cavaliers f3
donc on peut jouer ces quatre également
de toute façon on sera dans un
répertoire d'ouvertures du style des
deux des quatre mais ne pas jouer ces
quatre tout de suite donc conserver
l'option sur la casse et de ne pas la
pensée ça a des avantages et des
inconvénients
ce composant dire un petit peu plus en
quelques mots on va dire qu'on est vite
on évite certains systèmes qu'on
pourrait employer contre la défense est
indienne à savoir la taxe heinich par
exemple et ça fait partie des
inconvénients de joe et kevin f3 d'abord
des inconvénients mais on va dire que
cavalière 3 et un coût plus solide que
ses deux c4
d'une manière générale et un coût qui
évite la ninja beach les complications
en jouant que viège 3 maintenant on
évite notamment le grand big and co qui
a lieu après ses cinq crc 5 des 5 et b5
qui attaque tout le plan c quatre et on
évite aussi donc là pour ceux qui en
auraient peur à tort le gambit sur ces
quatre ou cinq donc qu'ils aient logobi
budapest cindy madame budapest à savoir
que laurent frayssinet à des résultats
excellents avec ce gambie sur internet
dans big qui n'est pas dénudées devenant
c5
quand même des 5 c'est la réaction
classique ici on à dire sur ce coup
maintenant si les noirs jouent de 7,6
après ses cartes on transpose dans une
baignoire on sent trop de commentaires
et si les noirs jouent g6
après ces trois on transpose dans une
pire qu voilà donc beaucoup de
transpositions possibles mais si
jean-marc degraeve choisi un coup il
n'ya pas bien réussi puisqu'il avait
déjà perdu contre marquette des nôtres
on secoue bessette b5 et il rejoue une
nouvelle fois c'est une ouverture
atypique assez rare quelles sont les
idées oui donc c'est une voiture
atypique mais disons que l'idée
principale de ce coupé sept dessins qui
est finalement d'attaqué donc d'attaquer
le prendre de l'isf à sallèles dan et
d'attaquer éventuellement le pur des 5
le plus vite possible puisqu'il ne peut
plus être soutenu par un pion par un
plan c est finalement donc là dans cette
position les blancs ne peuvent pas
installer de centre très facilement il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils réagissent face
à ce duo b 5e des cinq ces sacs pour
obtenir des cases
alors ils peuvent le faire soit en
france et 4 en jouant à quatre ce qui
leur permet finalement donc de en jouant
à quatre par exemple d'obtenir la case
sekkat où je peux venir éventuellement
première remarque donc si les blanchons
cavaliers c3 qui est beaucoup qu'on a
envie de jouer dans ce genre de position
pour jouer de 2,4 après eh bien tout de
suite les noirs de régis par des cadres
voilà et puis les jeunes gardois
développeurs du temps donc ça c'est un
des premiers avantages de ce couple est
simple c'est que ça évite le coup qui a
blessé trois donc effectivement comme tu
l'as dit e4 n'est pas possible c'est 4
apparemment ne l'est pas vraiment non
plus le coût principal dans cette
pétition jean-luc c'est fou j'ai cinq
pour menacer fou prend kavvadias fils
donc donné la peur de fou pour casser la
structure de plans des noirs aux îles
fidji 5 et le coût principal à savoir
que fout g5 et le coût que joe krainik
en général et il ya un an il s'était
joué à monaco une partie entre krainik
et et
et topalov topalov qui est le
spécialiste de cette position avec les
noirs et topalov l'avait emporté donc
peut-être qu'il ya quelques
inconvénients actuellement en tout cas
c'est une ouverture peut jouer et
probablement stuart n'avais pas envie de
rentrer dans des des lignes peu connu il
ya donc joué le coup c4 qui transpose
dans un an binh compte voilà donc là on
transpose dans un grand vide bengo donc
finalement stuart ne joue pas cavalier
f3 pour éviter le groupe benko mais
plutôt pour une envie de nous taper des
mots budapest c'est sans doute sa c4
donc l'option est en prise effectivement
ça c'est une remarque mais les noirs
sont obligés de le prendre ils peuvent
le prendre
donc c'est un vol à noter quand ils le
prennent ça permet aux plantes de
qualité 3 suivi de vaud 4 donc ça ils
n'ont pas vraiment envie puisque
l'option c4 après on va le récupérer
naturellement avec le foie fin donc
jean-marc degraeve choisi le plus malin
fou défaite mais je crois que le coût
normal aussi dans cette position c'est
sur ces quatre c'est de jouer tout
simplement g6 wii et sur pied en pro b 6
g sur cinq jours qu'on est là les blancs
prennent en biais en b 5 après on joue à
six comme dans le vide quand ils benko
donc oui là on arriverait dans des
positions typique du gambit bien qu en
jouant le coup donc j'ai this pions
prend b5 qui en prendrait 5 à 6 1 6 et
voilà donc on est des pollutions typique
avec qui on prend 1,6 pour les ventes
classiques et p6 pour les vins de
moderne tout à fait donc sur fion prend
pour résumer l'idée des noirs on va
jouer avec fu g7
ensuite on va jouer des six fou prend
1,6 on va échanger ses fautes case
blanche donc c'est un bandit puisqu'on
est un pion de moins mais on obtient
beaucoup de jeu avec les colonnes a et b
les deux tours bien placé et des pièces
qui se déploie très rapidement donc ça
c'est l'idée du gambit bain co c'est un
jeu très dynamique pour les noirs et ici
je te vois ton quest n'a pas envie de
prendre mes seins je tombe fou fou
bessette jean-marc n'a pas joué chelsea
si je vous paie 7 mc 2 26e donc
d'abaisser de cinq ou très classique
l'idée n'est pas de protéger de sur ces
quatre contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser non pas du tout l'idée de dams et
2 est tout simplement d'installer un pur
au centre et donc d'installer le pion à
eux en
le kart mc2 était le seul moyen de le
faire puisque si on revient dans l'autre
position qui a essayé trois toujours
impossible à cause de b4 encore qu'ils
gagneraient beaucoup de temps donc vous
mais cette dame ces deux géants français
4e 4 donc là nous y sommes les bleus ont
installé leur dure depuis ils vont jouer
qu'à laisser 3 et faut penser 4
maintenant très vite une structure de
pions qui est à peu près équilibré on a
une structure de plans qui à peu près
équilibré mais là il est clair que dans
cette dans ce schéma là les blancs ont
forcément un petit avantage puisqu'ils
peuvent installer un centre et les noirs
avec un fond v7 qui est finalement un
petit peu emmuré derrière ses deux pions
sans trop se retrouvent donc finalement
dans une situation délicate dans cette
position le coup classique pour les
noirs c'est de jouer le coup eux 7 6
justement pour faire revivre ce fou 17
jean luc mais jean-marc degraeve choisi
g6 ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
coup l'avancé de ce pion qui est devant
droit le pion à eux a été jouée par
stuart roncq ouest quand il avait les
noirs contre vladislav tkachiev aux
championnats d'europe à ohrid donc jean
marc s'est peut-être dit eh bien il est
très très au courant de cette position
puisqu'il a déjà joué avec les noirs
chaînon peu autre chose c'est possible
oui c'est tout à fait possible surtout
que stuart et essayiste de ces
ouvertures qui sont un petit peu aussi
assez original pas classique on va dire
donc si tu as probablement connais très
bien cette position avec les noirs et
il est très sage de la part de jean marc
de changer un petit peu de deux voies de
solution pour résumer après au cices les
blancs jouent qu'à laisser 3 on prend
des cinq pions prend on joue des coups
comme des 6 ou fawcett foot français 4
et il ya une position de benoni assez
curieuse assez bizarre où le fou n'est
pas venu angers7
c'est tout à fait jouable jean-marc
choisi le coup g7 g6 pourquoi pas ça
existe également vous prend ses quatre
très normal fou g7 est maintenant qu
avait laissé 3
les blancs ont sorti toutes leurs pièces
les noirs s'apprête à en faire autant
et dans cette position le coup très très
douteux choisi par jean-marc de g coup
un couple curieux jean luc tu va sans
doute essayer nous l'expliqué il joue
petit rock alors que des six paraissait
largement meilleur dans la mesure où
après petit rock et bien il permet à ce
genre de concours est de percer au
centre avec le 4 5
alors est ce qu'il a cherché à provoquer
les blancs ou alors est ce qui s'est dit
et ce qu'il s'est dit peu 5 c'est pas
bon donc je lui permet de le faire ou
c'est tout simplement un oubli je pense
pas que ça soit on oublie je pense que
jean-marc n'avait peut-être l'intention
de jouer des six il avait peur de jouer
trop trop classique cette position et
c'est vrai que vont quelquefois il
arrive dans ce type de position qu'on
laisse et les blancs poussé le centre
comme comme par 4,5 pour réagir en
contre finalement on laisse les blancs
installés leur masse de pions au centre
et on leur dit voilà tutu a poussé tout
est puant sentent maintenant on va voir
si tu est suffisamment bien développée
pour pour justifier cette avancée
c'était la technique de genre dans cette
partie mais apparemment ce n'était pas
la bonne première remarque quand on joue
au 5 et bien le foot bessette tout de
suite regagne en activité donc ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'il a fait ne
pas trop hésité à laisser cette
opportunité aux blancs en tout cas
stuart conquest le joueur sans compromis
il est là pour relever les défis et il
le fait puisqu'ils jouent eux cinq
cavaliers 1,8 et maintenant il faut
justifier cette avancée de pions donc
soit on gagne pièce tout de suite
soit on n'aurait pas dû avancer soit on
a une autre idée mais en tout cas si ces
avancées pour avancer et jouer petit
rock maintenant ce n'était pas une bonne
idée
non c'était pas une tribune
surtout que le veut le fou 17 ne demande
plus qu'à jouer dans cette position
si on joue petit rock je suppose qu'un
coup comme des six par exemple peuvent
être très gênant d'ici ce qui va
échanger des pions au centre échanger
des points centraux et donc allégé
clairement l'attention pour faire jouer
finalement les fous noir qui sont passés
bien passé voyez donc probablement
hk tu donc le goûter des jouets stewart
est probable en jeu le jeu le bon coup
dans cette position en tout cas ça fait
partie d'un plan tout à fait cohérent on
rappelle une fois de plus aux auditeurs
de diagonale que quand on a chassé le
cavalier m6 c'est le cavalier de défense
du petit rock
donc on joue eu cinq cas value8
maintenant tout est prêt pour une
attaque d'autant plus que les blancs
sorties toutes leurs pièces
le cavadee m6 n'est plus là puisqu'il a
dû partir en 1 8
donc tout est prêt il faut y aller h4 g4
ses positions et trivial mais il est
blanc veulent jouer h45 trivial genre
les fresques à mener c'est pas évident
forcément de trouver ce genre de choses
e 5 et h 4 c'est une réaction typique
mais peut-être pas trivial quand même je
parlais de la chatte avec le cavalier
1,8
c'est clair que lorsqu'on à ces deux
centres ses deux pions au centre aussi
bien installé et que la tour que le roi
n'a pas encore roque et le roi blanc on
voit que le roi gland est encore au
centre
dans cette position sur h 4,6 des noirs
jouent h5 la position risque d'être
délicate pour eux puisqu'ils à cela
casse g5 sur laquelle oui j'ai en plus
on peut envisager très bien des coups
comme 6 avec le pion g6 qui sera pris
défendu exactement
oui donc ils ne peuvent pas poussé ce
trio h donc forcément les blancs
arriveront à le pousser encore une fois
on va pousser h5 on va ouvrir ma colonne
h pour sept tours qui restait sur sept
colonnes ouverte
c'est quand même un bon point pour voir
pour cette attaque et en plus on voit
que les pièces blanches font bien
circuler sur les droites sur le roi noir
on voit que très vite le fou c'est un
peu passé on peut jouer trop rock
ramener encore du sang neuf avec une
nouvelle tournée
la dame blanche peut s'appeler par la
case e cat le pussy cat est pas mal
passé lequel ces trois prêts à bondir le
khalife 3 aussi moralité il ya un an
comment dire un haut potentiel d'attac
si on cherche les forts potentiels
d'attac la y en a yao potentiel impact
exactement bicis normal il faut attaquer
le centre obligé attaques sur les ailes
réaction au centre principe qu'on
apprend aux débutants mais qui est
évidemment valable au niveau des grands
maîtres
c'est un grand principe des échecs quand
on se fait attaquer sur les ailes il
faut ouvrir le centre pour justement
contre et un peu ce qu'est en train de
se passer
si ce que line in the beach h55 donc sur
tron quest lui la direction centre
attaques sur les ailes quand même voilà
donc h5 c'est tout à fait dans la
logique de cette position pions prend
1,5 et là on ne se bat pas du tout pour
reprendre ce qu on veut simple on n'a
pas envie spécialement de le reprendre
puisque quand il est là il bouge un peu
les pièces des noirs notamment le fou g7
en revanche maintenant que les cds blanc
non plus 11,5 et bien le cavalier six à
pouvoir revenir en défense ça c'est le
bon point pour les noirs h 30 et 6 h 30
g6 et là il faut continuer la table jean
luc alors il faut ramener des pièces en
jeu donc d'un m'éclate d'avocate le coût
de ce tueur compost la dame coulisses
sur la 4e roger vérité hk pour menacer
maths et on aura bien sûr des thèmes
d'attac avec des changes des fous
deux cases noires donc avec fortis est
ce qui est important c'est dans cette
position
ce on ne peut pas pousser le pion f pour
chasser la dame par fc peut-être cinq
parce qu'il y aurait une découverte en
échec à la découverte d'un très
dangereux le mortel découverte
et oui une l'antenne découverte donc des
cinq des six le fou sekkat qui attaque
faible crois donc non seulement la seule
défense ce serait tout à 2,7 mais en
plus pour jouer d'un port en bessin
points de flou on pourrait une
catastrophe ce qu'on veut donc ici f5
n'est pas possible
après damas quatre et six donc ne l'est
pas non plus donc 66 ans n'ai pas envie
de jouer pour le moment mais simplement
pour être été plus tard ici il faut
choisir la case du cavalier et c'est là
justement que jean-marc degraeve comme
et sa seconde erreur et dernière
d'ailleurs et donc jean bart avait une
petite chance de rentrer dans la partie
à ce moment là puissent revenir de
revenir en jean cavalier cavaliers f6
cavaliers 6 qui défendent est un petit
peu donc la case h7 vous permettez donc
sans droit d'être défendu
et finalement le cavalier qui avait une
action sur le centre plus plus plus
évidente que dans la partie puisqu'il a
ajouté un volet des six oui donc avec l
idée 6 on va y revenir
c'est dans cette position ce coup là qui
attaquent la dame et le fou en même
temps mais on va voir que ça se heurte
malheureusement ils attaquent de maths
extrêmement direct complètement force
est donc très efficace qui conduit un
résultat radical donc il fallait choisir
la case m6 c'est ce que nous allons
analyser tout de suite qu'elle durcisse
dame h4 jean-luc c'est normal on en a
marre de ces forces est dans cette
position la menace entre guillemets des
blancs c'est fou h6 pour échanger c'est
fou et ensuite asséné un mat avec des
machines speed à ma cheville une des
défenses pour les noirs il défend ce
qu'on peut proposer c'est le couple
cavalier b17 qui ne partent pas fasciste
mais qui le parent d'une façon assez
subtil donc là il ya énormément de
variantes ce qu'on va faire
jean-luc c'est pour vous montrer
quelques unes pour montrer la force de
la tacc des blancs et montre évidemment
l'aveyron critique dans ce genre de
position là le bon coup non un des
coudes attaques possibles qui n'est pas
le bon c'est le couffo l6 le couple
directement la fois ci ce qui menace
tous
mon fou pranger cette dame reprend rock
en ges à damas six échecs roi g8 et
dames h 8 échec et mat
donc c'est direct et là les noirs
doivent absolument couvrir la colonne h
en jean cavalier et 6 h 5
donc pour éviter toutes ces menaces
voyez donc leur projet 7 on peut prendre
je sais tout rapproche de sa taille et
la pointe c'est qu'après le coup g4g 4
qui al'air gagnant puisque si lecavalier
s'en va on a notre match on fait notre
match oui et si lecavalier s'en va pas
au premier venu mais là peut-être qu'un
coup comme tourache 8 finalement sens
bien du courage suit donc sûr qu on
prend cavaliers tout reprend pions et là
on voit que la dame en h4 et la tour en
rachats se retrouve un peu piégé bâtir
que la dame hkd doit bouger sinon elle
va être prise par la tour et quand elle
s'en va la torche en étant prises la
dame quand elle part ne peut pas
défendre cette tour h1 donc ici des
pertes matérielles pour les blancs et
perte de la partie tout simplement est
donc dans cette position les blancs ne
sont pas assez bien développés puisque
le roi n'est pas si le roi était si les
blancs avaient fait grand roque le poème
ne se poserait pas l'intervention sera
défendue et les blancs auraient donc
tout simplement une pièce de plus dans
cette position après kébé 17
donc nous revenons le dernier coup ses
cavaliers m6 attaque la dame damage 4
kebede cette fois çi c'est la première
tentative inefficace autre tentative
très intéressante jean-luc c'est le coup
j'ai dejé kart wii g2g 4 donc toujours
pour
pour pour justifier ce coup fourré le 6
donc j'ai 2 et 4 on contrôle la case
cavaliers enrage sat
voilà donc le cavalier ne peut pas venir
h5 et on se dit ok bon maintenant ça toi
de jouer mais de toute façon moi même là
c'est ça je jouerai fou h6 koki larifou
projet 7 et mat et mat
d'accord ça va être très très simple
alors deux exemples de mauvaise défense
pour les noix alors on va les donner
tout de suite par exemple tour vite en
se disant sûr fou h 10 je fais deux fois
de suite
voilà donc ça c'est une position qui est
très très classique dans ce type d'
attaque sur la colonne h contre un pion
ghetto on peut l'obtenir par exemple
dans la 6ieme dragon est dans cette
position donc le cookie qui viennent
immédiatement c'est de donner le fou
donc de jouer fou h61 f8 c'est la soirée
thema voilà donc grandes thématiques on
menace dame prend à schwyz échec et mat
dans cette position on est forcé de
jouer roi prend d'un prend la fuite
échec oui cavaliers revient sur la case
g8 mais là le problème c'est que les
pièces noires sont complètement
inexistante lé droit on peut tout
simplement asséné le coup tout rachat h7
sur la septième rangée pour menacer dame
g7 suivie de dames
prends droit suisse ne prend elle a fait
donc ici on voit les caisses noires
complètement complètement resserré
complètement à la rue tout simplement le
mat est imparable
c'est normal d'ailleurs et en plus les
blancs n'ont même pas sacrifier de
matériel dans cette variante
donc c'est un thème d' attaque très très
classique que l'on propose ici sur la
défense tour aux 8 avec des fourrages
six fois de suite et bien le foot ne
revient pas ailleurs sur la diagonale
parce que sinon les noirs rejouerez
dessous g7
il faut venir sur la case f8 maintenant
sur flu g7 on prend gsm et là c'est le
match fort c'est donc tour à huit c'est
un premier coup de défense
pas très malin sogecap un deuxième coup
de défense ça serait de se dire d'anne
decis normal puisque sur x h 6 dont
jouit d'un pro d2 oui mais là il y a un
coût qui est très astucieux ses
cavaliers c'est 3d qui essaient trois
ans rien donc un coût assez curieux ont
saccagé la dame on attaque la dame et on
bat natoora mais finalement ce n'est pas
grave puisque on couvre l'échec si on en
prend à il n'y a pas d'échec et donc on
peut continuer donc ce cette combinaison
de maths qui est directrice qui est
imparable on doit dans sa position de
donner une pièce enjoint cavaliere 5
oui et c'est la fin on je vous prends et
fut d'abord et instruments prend un
cavalier avec une pièce de plus on a
tout à fait donc ici on n'a pas peur de
donner
sachant que sur celle des 6 11 x 6 quand
même c'est pas grave on va prendre
tellement de matériel avec cette attaque
on peut on sacrifier une petite partie
le bon coup de défense dans cette
position alors il faut le trouver ça
c'est pas évident on a mis assez
longtemps elle trouvait jean luc le bon
coup de défense le seul pour les noirs
ici c'est de jouer le coup hausse est
aussi de jouer de 7 6 a encore une fois
ça ça reprend donc la théorie d'in the
beach qui disait donc attaquer les
réactions au centre là il faut encore
réagi au centre on voit que ans
en créances vis-à-vis entre le pion aux
6 et le pion des 5 on ouvre la diagonale
du fou 17 très dangereusement en même
temps finalement d'une certaine manière
on chasse environ on évite un petit peu
le jeu immédiat le jeu direct donc du
fou c4 est finalement aussi de la damage
4 puisque on voit que le cavalier m6 ne
contrôle h7 donc la dame h4 ne peut pas
maté donc si par exemple sur lyon prend
le 6e si les blancs je vois bien
pro-russe il n'y aurait aucune menace à
prendre est publiée le 3 alors j'ai
envie que tout se passe t-il sur x
justice quand même dans quelle mesure
est ce que ce coup ci par là l'onas donc
sur x justice quand même on devrait dans
cette position je voulais cavaliers
prend des cinq cavaliers prend dessin
est sévère pour l'astuce c'est l'
échange des dames donc justement on a
ouvert la diagonale de la dame noire ce
qui permet ici de menacer un échange de
dames donc les blancs peuvent se dire je
suis malin et je reste là je joue damas
trois ça c'est possible
maintenant on joue cavalier français 3
voilà donc ça c'est la meilleure suite
fou quand j'ai cette fange et 7 et on
n'a pas peur en un an on reprend sert
qu'on a chassé la dame de la garde ça
c'était assez important et donc il peut
s'ensuivre échec perpétuelle bahamas si
ces chats croyais 6 et 26 et la mazda
match 4 s'il est noir rouge et
s'inquiètent d'un projet 5 mat le fameux
matin d'un projet 7 et les blancs sont
plus ou moins obligé de répéter les
goûts puisque les noirs menace foutront
17 et blanc n'ont pas moyens d'augmenter
encore la portée de leurs attaques
il ya beaucoup de variantes qui se
termine comme ça
par une nulle donc ça c'est l'idée 2,6
dans cette position nous allons enlever
toutes les flèches et donc conclure sur
le fait que six menace qu à l epr
options des cinq qui gagne un temps avec
les changes des dames et ça c'est très
important donc le bon coup d' attaque
dans cette position c'est fou j'ai cinq
jean-luc coup tout à fait logique et
apprécié on prend des cinq la pression
devient extrêmement complexe et on peut
dire d'une manière générale que les
blancs arrive à faire mieux
après année noire arrive à faire donc on
peut dire que les noirs ne sont en hors
de danger dans cette position donc c'est
vraiment compliqué pour continuer la
tacc il faut regarder les coups comme
fou prend des singles comme cavalier
prend des cinq mais n'y a pas de match
direct ça c'est très important et noir
dans cette paix si on a des cinq des 4
et quand le fou beissat revient en jeu
c'est très pénible premier plan le plus
important donc pour trouver ce coup de
défense aussi c'est qu'il faut se poser
la question dans cette position que
menace les blancs et 1 h x 6 avec bien
de matériel faut donc trouver n'importe
quelle solution qui évite ce coup et là
on arrive à jouer
e.cisse le seul groupe défense un autre
coup très intéressant d'attac dans cette
position c'est le dernier coup qu'on va
vous montrer puisque ça ça commence à
faire beaucoup avant de vous montrer
quand même l'estocade duster frank west
oui donc lui donner coude à taxer foulée
5 foulée 5 ça ça vient d'eux c'est un
concept gasparo bien
kasparov dit régulièrement voilà le
problème dans cette position c'est que
les noirs la table du autre cavalier
noir se défendre mutuellement et défend
toutes les cases il faut donc le cas c
est pour ça le couffo b5 vient à
l'esprit avec une variante
transformation davantage on peut appeler
ça sert que toutes les initiatives des
blanches va se transformer en autre
chose
supposons par exemple coup à six assez
logique
bon je vois il faut prendre 17e
je comprend 17 d'ailleurs on jouerait
plutôt x 6 x 6 non c'est pas fasciste le
groupe je ne sais plus quel coût tout
simplement
oui on prend 17 et on prend 1,5 c'est
quelque chose comme ça bon je m'en
rappelle plus les analyses très
détaillées sont vivraient chez notre
partenaire sport échec donc vous pour en
savoir plus sur cette position après le
coup food et 5 en allant sur sport
achète pour consulter justement un petit
peu des variantes plus compliqué plus
pointus puisque la partie sera
disponible dès demain sur le site sport
échec c'est à dire normalement à peu
près tout le temps qu'il faut a
d'ailleurs précisé que les ventes qui
suivent après foulée 500 cas c'est
exhaustif donc il y en a beaucoup
je crois que tu fous comme s'intéresser
à la partie donc quel s des six dans
cette position là matches quatre
normales menace matt donc là c'est
simple c'est beaucoup plus simple après
qu'eric d61 jean-luc puisqu'on n'a pas à
les éliminer ce qu'avait dit artiste
l'isf g7 ont fait des menaces directes
avec des coups simples m6 est la seule
défense
hélas le coup qui a peut-être échappé à
jean marc degraeve c'est le reclassement
de ce fou c4 qui ne sert plus à rien ici
puisque le tour des cinq est sévèrement
bloqué par kiev des six c'est le
courroux des trois coups très très fort
il revient attaquer toutes les cases
blanches
donc c'est malin ça va mal ça fait ch
eck suivi de frangy six échecs et mat
échec et mat e4 c'est la seule défense y
en a pas d'autres tous les autres coûts
perdent très très rapidement calé prend
1,4 très logique
donc là on voit dans cette pression il
ya égalité matérielle la menace des
blancs c'est de jouer
la menace on va la voir bientôt il y en
a beaucoup notamment avec damas tête et
kg 5
de toute façon jean marc degraeve ne
peut pas l'éviter oui d'ailleurs vous
expliquer que si si jean marc deleval va
jouer le coup m6 auparavant c'est qu'il
aurait pu aussi jouer f5 mais il ne
voulait pas laisser la possibilité aux
blancs d'installer un cavalier sur la
case g5 qui est très fort qui valide
attaque il exactement qui contrôlerait
la case afsset il empêcherait donc droit
de sortir de sa boîte et ce serait un
match rapide et après cavani l5 dans
cette position il est un gain en ligne
assez joli donc à ces thématiques vous
pouvez réfléchir bien à cette position
matériellement cette égalité bon il faut
quand même que les blancs conclu parce
que s'il faut rien y avoir fermeture des
cinq
donc il faut agir tout de suite c'est
vrai que ce genre de pression peut se
retourner en un instant moi ici les
blogs sont pas précis mais là le maté
forcer le maté forcer le matin c'est
donc le ghana est 3ème set et là
cavalier e g5 échec au roi le seul coup
pour éviter se ferme et srwt a vite mais
ça perd toute la maison puisqu'après
d'un projet six échecs roi 17 fou prend
cavaliers avec cinq échecs lequel et qui
vient aux six attaquants toute la
baraque
c'est inacceptable donc naturellement
jean-marc degraeve pranger 5 et
maintenant le match est vraiment forcer
jean luc maton 4 donc tactique
voilà cavaliers ou cinq cavaliers de
cinq échecs au roi donc là sur huit ça
se passe de commentaire d'un projet six
tours est peut-être forcée et d'un proto
à chaque et math rock 6 seul coup ils
font monter droit d'un projet 6 leroy
encore en échec est obligé d'aller
manger le cavalier donc le cadeau
grecque en 3.5 d'un v6 donc là le roi
pelé à gauche ou à droite
c'est comme il veut mais de toute façon
qu'il aille en d4 il sera bloqué par
pour ses 5 et silva en chef catherine
sera bloquée par le songe est cinglant
de toute façon roi des quatre roues et
15 dames aux catnat pas mal pas mal pas
mal et je donc ce tueur trop quest a
sacrifié deux pièces à sacrifier les
deux cavaliers pour faire monter le roi
et une fois que l'euro est au centre de
l'échiquier on a
au tableau de maths à noter que c'est
assez rare que les joueurs continuent
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au match en
compétition entre dos quand m oui mais
bon ça fait 22 coups donc c'est pas
l'anglais s'est pas beaucoup je suis un
petit peu c'est donc une miniature de ce
tueur frank west qui remporte le tournoi
anniversaire de clichy les 20 ans du
club de clichy avec une très très belle
partie des 20 ans du club 22 coup pas
mal
stuart qu est ce donc on le félicite et
nous allons tout de suite passé jean luc
à notre deuxième grand volet d'actualité
c'est le tournoi de maïs le festival de
minds qui a lieu en allemagne
mindset à la frontière luxembourgeoise
ou pas exactement donc minds d'enclos
mindset si mayence c'est à côté de
francfort
c'est exactement une vingtaine de
kilomètres de francfort ce festival à
l'allemande donc été organisée il ya
beaucoup de choses il ya un grand open
avec plus de 500 joueurs qui ont
participé à un tournoi semi rapides
gagné par michael adams
il y avait également le tournoi d'échecs
avancé michael adams contre picard
l'écho donc ça c'est les échecs fide
affichèrent random chess donc on met les
pièces différemment sur des casques
curieuse finalement c'est peter l'écho
qui a gagné qui a battu michael adams
donc on considère ça comme étant un jeu
de calcul mais en tout cas il n'y a pas
beaucoup de théorie c'est un désavantage
le gros événement évidemment domain
c'était le match
wisches manhattan à nantes contre
vladimir kramnik on vous rappelle le
score avant de commenter notre deuxième
partie krainik gagne la quatrième partie
donc que des nuls quand ils gagnent la
quatrième dans la neuvième partie à
londres revient au score encore eu lieu
la 10e donc cinq partout en 10 parties
des parties semi-rapides beats de
départage premières parties de blitz
anand a les blancs et donc on va voir ce
que ça donne vite ces cinq minutes
chacun ça va très très vite
donc le cas où ce que ça a donné 4 c 5
grammes il jouit sicilienne dans ce bus
de départage
en général ils jouent la carotène ou 400
cavaliers f3 cavaliers c6 d'état sida
ouverte voilà pas grand chose à dire tu
en prends des quatre qu'elle prend des
quatre dom v6 alors là il faut faire un
commentaire
parce que ce coût d'un v6 est assez rare
on dit régulièrement aux débutants qu'il
faut pas sortir la dame prématurément
donc explications d'un v6 donc c'est un
coût qui n'est pas vraiment orthodoxe
mais finalement c'est fait pour
pourchasser ce cavalier la case centrale
oui première remarque si on veut le
défendre parfois 3 des actions b de
reprise voilà donc ça c'est important
on peut le défendre par le penser mais
ce n'est pas ces trois ça empêche les
blogs se développer normalement et qui s
est roi c'est pas un coup et harmonieux
voilà tout à fait donc ça empêche le
développement des pièces blanches donc
le coup les deux coups logis pas cette
position semble être cavaliers dessin ou
cavaliers p 3 oui donc à dessein que ce
serait plutôt l'idée de jouer avec
calais c3 après et cahiers des 5 ou avec
ses quatre en tout cas de chasser dans
un premier temps la dame par parfois par
fouet 3 mais bon cavalier b3 et le coût
normal dans cette position donc
classique voilà cavaliers mais trois
cavaliers f6 maintenant on déplace ses
caisses vers le centre capable et c3po 6
on essaie d'obtenir un développement
très rapide donc l'idée de ce coup c'est
de sortir pour l'instant la thèse b4 et
donc mettre la pression sur eux tuant
quatre éventuellement menacer faut
planquer les sept corps voilà est
habituellement dans cette mission je
crois qu'on jouait en général le fou
c'est un e3 pour chasser la dame
oui et après on essaie de développer les
pièces de manière classique avec donc la
garde dab sur ce thème c'est cette année
ses 700 jouets ou deux par exemple photo
où j'ai trois riches départ et que j'ai
trois réfugiés 2 ça donne une position
tout à fait normal sauf que donc on voit
que les noirs ont perdu un temps ils ont
joué d'amd 6 puis dams et 7 mai le
cavaly est revenu fin classe b merkel y
tomber trois hommes s'adonnent des
sicilienne normal sauf que lequel est
tombé 3 et
tout au lieu d'être en b 4 c'est
exactement pareil sinon au passage j'en
profite pour vous signaler que la leçon
sur la cité hand acheteurs viennent de
commencer
donc on peut voir la première qui a été
fait donc avec jean-luc chavanon 6 l'âge
d'or si ça vous intéresse il voulait en
savoir plus sur tout les sicilienne et
bien diagonale son ouverture la défense
ccn nageurs dams et 7
donc ça c'est possible mais c'est le
couffo 3 jean-luc sûr aussi ce choix
différent de match nadal en est très
très faim psychologiquement dans cette
situation là puisque anne ont donc à
jouer d'avs 2 donc il joue un coût
original on va tenir en même temps très
très agressif puisque on voit qu'il ya
les blancs
n'ont pas l'intention de faire le petit
rock ils ont plutôt l'intention de faire
le grand roque qui vaut jeux photos et
vente
ils menacent directement fouet trois
écrans rock et sur le coup que je me
crame nikki dont canon a trouvé un autre
placement pour s'en fout c'est à dire
les 15 des deux oui puisque la fouille 3
pas vraiment satisfaisant puisque après
dams et c'est tout simplement on peut
pas jouer grand roque vraiment à cause
de foot en c3 qui déstructure est qui
dévisagent rem la structure de lyon
autour du roi blanc l'on peut même jouer
france et 3 avant d'annoncer sa mort
elle même joué ses trois échecs
intermédiaire avant d'inviter 7 qui sera
encore plus fort donc issifou des deux
je sois très logique d'aaland krainik
joue petit rock est ici maintenant il
faut justifier ce placement notamment
deux qu'il faut faire quelque chose ici
parce qu'on ne peut plus sortir nos
pièces d'une façon rationnelle est
normal il faut chasser ce coupé 407
l'air d'être le premier point ensuite
viré la rb6 est ensuite commencé à
attaquer en chine à trois classes
normales en chasse le fou fou aux 7 est
maintenant grand roque
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire là dessus les
noirs ont perdu beaucoup de temps
comparé une sicilienne normal puisqu'ils
ont joué donc fourbe et 4 puis fawcett
dmb 6 puis ils vont jouer dames c'est
cette c'est quasiment forcé pour pouvoir
pousser les pions b mais en contrepartie
ils ont obtenu le fait que quand le pion
b arrive sur un sdk très bien ils soient
en contact direct avec l'option à 3 donc
ça ça accélère la taille des noirs ça
accélère la tag les noirs on va voir
aussi
que les blancs ont un petit avantage
supplémentaire aussi c'est que la dame
en e2 est très utile elle permet tout
simplement l'avancé des pions direct à
les droits puisqu'elle contrôle la case
g2g 4 pas besoin de jouer trois très
important des six tout de suite g4g 4
c'est le signe de la course
c'est un signal top départ en général
dans ce type de 6 yens quand on a
développé ses pièces il faut pousser ses
pions le plus vite possible en face du
roi c'est vrai pour les longs et pour
les noirs c'est valable pour les deux
donc les deux joueurs vont se passer
c'est la course à six coups logique on
veut jouer dams et 7 sans encombre puits
b 5 b 4 c'est normal donc là anand g5
qu'elle est 17h 420 vite
qu'y at il à dire il a part que dans
cette question jean luc on peut quand
même dire que les blancs ont l'air
sérieusement en avance puisqu'ils sont
déjà jusqu'ici alors que les noirs ont
juste poussins pour l'instant joué à six
et ils ont encore la dame qui bloquent
des blocs l'option b donc on peut dire
faible en ont quand même pris une avance
on peut dire que les blancs une belle
position mais il faut quand même
concluant faut arriver jusqu'à jusqu'au
bout encore faut-il conclure dames c'est
cette f4 pourquoi pas le coup h5
je pense qu'on peut dire que c'était une
autre alternative oui c'était notre
internet avec l'idée g6 quand même c'est
l'idée c'est vraiment on n'a pas peur de
sacrifier du matériel on joue h5 g6 on
ouvre toutes les lignes autour de roi
noir avec une attaque en général assez
forte
anand préfère prendre son temps il joue
le coup f4 b5 toujours la course
donc là on attend soit un coût km 5 soit
un coup comme ashton qui vient nombre
dans sa position choisie le petit coup
tranquille le geste technique on peut
dire un coude attentes ou a apparemment
un coude attente le cours à berne alors
jean-luc pourquoi est ce que cette
sécurité est nécessaire en tout cas
pourquoi est-ce que canon date choisie
du roi b1
avant quoi que ce soit peut-être parce
que dans cette position après le coupé 4
les noirs ne contrôle plus là
la case c4 par exemple l'idée des
inconvénients et finalement les noirs
dans cette position n'ont peut-être pas
de coups plus utile que ce couleur donc
alors que l'euro en baisse sera mieux
placé de toute façon d'accord donc tout
simplement il aurait voulu attendre des
4 et mehdi ben vas-y joue b4 de toute
façon tu vas le faire ça ne menace rien
en grand bain sera mieux placé et c'est
sûr donc je le mets tout de suite
l'autre explication qui est rationnel
également c'est que c'est un beat and
envie de jouer vite
il n'avait pas envie de choisir tout de
suite entre 9,5 et h5 il s'est dit je
vais d'abord au bénin pour éviter de se
faire planter des échecs je ne sais pas
quoi oui mais c'est vrai que s'il jouait
le 5 d'armor il ya un cavalier qui peut
venir sur 5 puis s'écartent oui c'est
quand même un inconvénient
voilà sûr et sain qu'il y avait dit aux
cinq d'abord puis le calédonien en c4
alors que en jouant droit bien donc b4
et le coût quasi forcée des noirs puis
on prend les quatre cadrans b4 il peut
maintenant jouer f5 tranquillement
puisque la casse ces 4es les blindés par
le duo dan fouts dont il ya plus de
cavaliers qui vont arriver sur cette
case qui était une case très très
menaçante au tour du roi f5 krainik joue
tourbe ebit est ici ça aurait pu
chauffer si hollande avait joué le coup
f 5 et 6 oui ça aurait pu chauffer donc
à n'en avait la possibilité de gagner du
matériel immédiatement dans cette
position en jean f 5 à 6 on va expliquer
calmement et sans cap 6-7 1/7 fils de
pions apparemment mais ça se déroule
très vite
première remarque si les noirs juifs ou
des 8 eh bien on prend g7
et puis on joue à 5 g 6 avec une
explosion complète la position nord va
être complètement ouverte et ça ça va
chauffer donc les deux morts sont
obligés de prendre
on reprend et les noirs prennent encore
avec le fou cette fois puisque la menace
des blancs c'est un tour g1 est d'alger
2 par exemple réfléchissent bref si
lecavalier prend il y aura impressionné
non pas de défense après que directement
fois ci c'est même une mince imparable
bon on va dire que enfin de vente n'est
peut-être pas aussi efficace qu'elle
semble fou prentice donc dans cette
position de venir vous trouver ces faut
acheter un contrat intéressant toujours
pour faire ton général d'alger 2 et fuji
cet échec donc on va expliquer tout de
suite par exemple après tours 8
eh bien là c'est direct tour j'ai un
échec rouages suite d'alger 2 la menace
est fou g7 suivie d'un projet sept
matchs ou font preuve 6 avec un attrape
id imparable donc ça c'est un premier
cas où ça arrive vite fourrage 6
les noirs sont donc obligés de sacrifier
la qualité et oui il faut quand même un
vrai mais expliquer donc aux
téléspectateurs que le sacrifice de
qualité dans la défense sicilienne est
l'armé principale donc de défense des
noirs
c'est une c'est une solution qui arrive
extrêmement souvent on sacrifie la
qualité pour un pion là c'est le cas et
on se retrouve donc après [ __ ] en
fuite travail et prend la fuite avec une
position compliquée évidemment compliqué
puisqu'on a une qualité de moins mais un
jeu de pièces mineurs qui est quand même
très très très très intéressant le fou
sans totalement factice qui quand même
extrêmement fort le tout les pièces
noires voilà qui qui qui joue avec la
tourbe ebit sur la colonne des dons qui
exercent tous deux une pression sur le
plan b 2 le cavalier de l'es4 qui est
quand même sur un très très bel avant
postes qui peut sacrifier n'importe quel
moment et la dame c7 qui qui est là
aussi donc une position où nous en
sommes déplacés et le cavalier peut
revenir éventuellement sur g6 et e5 le
foudre solide le fou noir viendra sur 17
par exemple pour contrôler les caisses
g8 et après il va trouver falloir
trouver une solution avec les avec les
blancs pour mater le roi noir
effectivement sinon c'est mathéou se
faire mater dans cette position les
noirs eux vont trouver des solutions
pour amplifier la date c'est évident ici
une position peu claires une qualité de
moins c'est un sacrifice de qualité
totalement thématiques dans la défense
sicilienne
il faut donc revenir pour comprendre le
choix danang qui n'a pas voulu jouer 6
il avait sans doute pas envie de perdre
avec les blancs parce qu'après il sait
que c'est dur il
on n'avait pas envie de perdre il avait
aussi envie de trouver une solution qui
évite et éviter des possibilités
dynamique pour son adversaire
ils voulaient tout simplement calmer le
jeu donc il jouit des de f4 ils
attaquent donc le pion des six il fait
jouer sa tour d un est dans cette
position finalement et les noirs n'ont
pas de coût extrêmement extrêmement
utile autre remarque jean-luc labadens
maintenance et tf6 beaucoup plus
sérieusement il ya beaucoup plus
dangereux que tout à l'heure
évidemment puisque ça gagnait tout de
suite à cause du plan d'ici sans prise
il va falloir installer une pièce sur
cinq tôt ou tard donc je crois qu'une
chronique a pris un f5 d'abord il a pris
une femme d'abord il fait toujours sable
à dire chronique il prend 25 il aime
bien prendre et 5
il a peut-être peur de hisser sa
prouesse comprendre sur presse à un pion
prend avec cinq cavaliers aux cinq
maintenant la menace directe c'est fou
c'est vite prend quant à elle 5 est le
plus grave là dedans c'est pas qu'on ait
pris un pion c'est simple et donc le
fond f5 devient terrible avec la même
pression sur ces 2 c'est inacceptable
donc défense d'aaland fois je crois la
structure d'opium ici est meilleure pour
les blancs légèrement puisque ces deux
options sont tout seul il peut y avoir
des cahiers des cinq éventuellement mais
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que les noirs
sont très actifs et surtout après le
coup de crâne nick tour vite en tout 8
qui est probablement la faute décisif
dans cette position mais bon il était
difficile de trouver une alternative
de toute façon à partir de maintenant ça
chauffe très très vite
ah non on ne lésine pas sur le matériel
il ne compte même plus c'est le signe de
l'attaqué
il sait plus trop comment améliorer ses
pièces que je fais à tana non il n'a pas
envie d'enlever la tour 2 h 1 parce que
cette tour elle est belle et donc ils
envoient les pions g6 cookies ferrals
encore une fois un sacrifice très
thématiques dans cette
défense sicilienne donc on ouvre les
lignes là on voit que le purger six
attaques le pion à vii et le pion f7 et
que forcément donc même s'il est perdu
les noirs vont devoir ouvrir un petit
peu le le mur qui en face du roi noir
l'écologie les ouvrières voilà donc le
roi le roi noir ne sera plus en sécurité
dans gabut coup pions projet 6 là il ne
faut pas prendre tout de suite sinon le
cavalier viendrai reprendrai composition
assez solide on prend donc en main 5
intermédiaires qui on prend et
maintenant tu reproches et 6 donc là
apparemment tout est normal
pion projet 6 ça a l'air bien solide
pour les noirs c'est vrai les noirs sont
pas malinois contrôler la casse et 4 par
exemple par la dame dans le ccap tête
interne ils cassent des saints qui est
contrôlé par le cavalier en bekkat et la
case aussi c'est contrôlé par le fou le
foudroie les noirs défend bien mais il
reste un petit espace donc allé droit
bien sûr un petit pion à avancer encore
un petit pion le petit pion h
et malheureusement ce petit plus on va
faire des dégâts dans le roc noir h5
coup qui a l'air très fort ici
effectivement la colonne h he s ouvrir
et ça c'est dramatique c'est
inacceptable puisque après la dame
passant h5 et on se retrouve avec une
attaque à la jean marc degraeve enfin
allaster trop quest dam tour sur la
colonne âge ça fait très très mal
surtout quand ya pas de calais m6 en
défense on l'a déjà dit on le redit est
ici cramique à oublier justement la
petite pointe il avait prévu de jouer
cinq dans cette position l'idée c'est
que sur ton projet sicilia apparemment
foot français 2 mais on va voir que
c'est pas tout à fait vrai puisque après
psion prend six chroniques
c'était risqué a prononcé deux partants
comme tactique en était un techno
réfléchir de les spectateurs réflexion
que se passe-t-il
ça a l'air très fort cet échec mais il
ya un problème c'est si loin d'un
profond dans des grands fous ces deux
incroyables sacrifice de dames
quel programme et maintenant nous
enchaînons avec
le match fou aux six échecs royer fuite
forcée et maintenant maintenant un coup
tours h 1 h 8 night
mais exactement puisque donc le roi est
enfermé bloqué par ses propres pièces
sur les 80 il peut pas monter à cause et
du fou éduction il aura suffi d'un seul
mais y en a deux donc effectivement un
joli dessin d'ailleurs au temps du roi
du manque d espace h 30 g 6
on ne peut pas jouer vous pensez de et
là c'est un drame pour chronique qui
n'avait de toute évidence pas vu ce
petit coup ce sacrifice de dames
donc là il se retrouve tout simplement
perdants après fou prend h3 bon layada
match 5 qui gagne en lee ann on ne l'a
pas vu parce qu'on est en blitz et il
sait que sa position est gagnante après
tampon h 30 pourquoi est ce qu'elle est
gagnante parce qu'un pion g6 c'est
vraiment trop fort
la menace dans cette position jean-luc
ces deux thématiques tourache 828 roi
prend ensuite et après damas cinq échecs
suivi de damages cet échec et dash 8
échec et mat
voilà ça c'est tout à fait thématiques
quand on a une tour en sur une colonne
verte on peut donner la tour pour passer
la dame qui est une pièce plus fortes et
qui permet justement de faire des échecs
en diagonale donc en passant par la case
h est très important foucher cinq
cavaliers ou quatre fois f4 ou faut
acheter c'est pareil ici s'est terminée
sous gestion lidé jean-luc c'était
évidemment de couvrir en jouant fois ci
ce qui a lieu 4 x 4 et maintenant coup
très fort coup de massue
k&b c5 contre-pied c'est pas sur la
colonnade qu'on va gagner c'est avec
l'échec en c4 qui est devenue maintenant
imparable toutes les pièces blanches
sont rentrés on voit un duo de cavaliers
super impressionnant en quatre et c5 qui
contrôlent donc tout un tas de gaz
autour du roi
ça c'est tout les cas ce contrôle est au
tour du roi noir ça fait peur il ya plus
de défense contre dame c4 maths et
annonce imposant ce beat et bat donc le
champion du monde james à jean-luc donc
c'était un match deux champions du monde
entre le champion de la fidh et
chaponost membrane games et ses méchants
l'union de là
feed qui s'est imposé c'était un peu le
hasard puisque c'est un match de blitz
et anan est redoutable en glisse et en
asie travnik au 6 mai mais un ajout très
vite dans cette partie de cette un
joueur très rapide fin de la partie
commenté donc nous allons enchaîner avec
l'actualité le nombre reste du monde
surtout en france d'ailleurs puisqu'il
ya eu la parution des classements fille
d alors jean-luc notamment la liste
française qui est assez intéressante
puisque joël lautier pulvérise son
record historique et atteint la barre
des 2675 points elo ce qu'elle situe
dans les 20 meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
en visuel gauthier qui nous impressionne
et qui pourra donc jouer le grand prix
de la fidh de ce qu'il fait partie donc
des 40 meilleurs joueurs du monde des
mêmes des 32 joueurs meilleurs joueurs
du monde et il pourra donc jouer ce
grand prix et joël lautier qui confirme
finalement c'est c'est son travail avec
avec vladimir kramnik son travail de
solennité l'entraîneur et maintenant ça
commence à payer ses fruits curieusement
donc s'avérer paye assez assez nettement
puisque on se rappelle qu'il avait fait
une très mauvaise performance au tournoi
d'ohrid en macédoine
il avait perdu quelques points et l'osce
a déjà été comptabilisé donc sinon il y
aurait eu encore plus ça aurait été
encore mieux mais donc je vois le lotier
meilleurs joueurs français sur cette
nouvelle liste est de toute évidence le
plus fort joueurs au niveau réel il a
donc de 1675
il est suivi juste après par etienne
bacrot 2653 c'est stupéfiant etienne
bacrot qui est la révélation finalement
pour pour ce nouveau classement dont une
aurait une petite révélation puisqu'on
connaît tout le monde connaît très très
bien et yann mai
mais c'est vrai que etienne a très très
bien joué il a été très sérieux lors de
la coupe du monde
à cannes il a il a joué très
sérieusement cette saison et ils
méritent ils méritent donc ce classement
il utile place juste devant donc son
camarade de club
vladislav top chef qui lui par contre
fait donc une chute une chute une chute
assez sévère puisque il avait fait deux
d'excellents résultats ces les années
précédentes et actuellement il est en
baisse de régime ça se sent et sans
classes ont donc en souffrir oui tout à
fait plaitis la tcat chef donc
troisièmes avec 2650 quelque chose 40 et
2 45 bien descendu un petit peu moins qu
etienne quatrième position nous avons
notre star de dax donc le jeune laurent
frayssinet qui à 2606 points et l'eau il
passe la barre des 2600 il est donc trop
content mais oui donc ce qui est un coin
pour ce nouveau classement des joueurs
français c'est que plein de joueurs ont
dépassé la barre des 2600 pour la
première fois donc laurent frayssinet a
dépassé cette barre des 2600 c'est c'est
un très très gros bond et
il nous montre que les échecs chez les
jeunes joueurs français se porte
extrêmement bien laurent frayssinet qui
a gagné le grand prix et du sénat et qui
en très grande forme actuellement 2606
donc pour laurent en dessous on à
jean-marc degraeve 2602 andry sokolov
2602 yassif dorfman 2602 donc tout le
monde à 2600 beaucoup de joueur en 2006
sont jean-luc toi tu es monté jusqu'à
2511 tuba taux record historique
également au passage
voilà donc pour les performances des
joueurs français qui se porte pas si mal
quand même je voudrais te faire
intervenir sur le mercato des clubs
donc on en a parlé énormément aidé jean
claude - donc tu as peut-être des
éléments nouveaux nous apporter depuis
la semaine dernière à ou des transferts
des joueurs qui partiraient d'un club à
un autre
attendez à ce que bon apparemment il
semblerait que
q certains joueurs ont signé donc leur
transfert à kaïssa comme ça on en a
parlé la semaine dernière mais ça a été
signée hier ça a été signée hier donc
voilà c'est confirmé c'est confirmé
laurent frayssinet arnaud hauchard igor
nataf et marie se bagues sont parties
pour qu'elles savent ça s'est passé dans
la douleur dans la douleur on n'en dira
pas plus
dans cette émission la semaine prochaine
toujours l'actualité des échecs
on vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
émission jean lecomte remercie d'être
venus merci web et donc on vous donne
rendez vous jeudi prochain
21h30 merci